anti-trump Hollywood liberal Debra
Messing is at it again fresh off her
call to out Trump donors
she's now raising eyebrows for
retweeting an outrageous insult against
the president's family the tweet calling
Ivanka Trump and Jared Kushner national
security threats Wow
Jesse look I feel bad for Debra Messing
and I'll tell you why in a minute but
let's make fun of her for a little while
first why would you that I think you
should just stay off Twitter you know
take the El from last week cool off
listen to your group your entourage
knows what's best I would go on a little
hiatus call it a Twitter vacation then
come back refreshed and you can kind of
dip your toes back in yeah does she have
an entourage were they what makes you
say that they all these Hollywood people
have people you know she's got managers
she's got lawyers yeah here's why I feel
it's like the member of the boy in
plastic bubble that was the John
Travolta film he didn't know what the
world outside was like and that's what
she is like bad I feel bad that she
she's gonna continue doing this because
she doesn't know the world outside her
bubble attention is a hell of a drug she
last week when we all were like wow
she's had a terrible week she actually
thought she had a great week she's had a
great don't you think
you think this is a career no I think
it's good for her attention level oh yes
right yeah she likes the attention it
wasn't like oh wait I touched the hot
stove I shouldn't do that again now
she's like oh I know what I'll do I'll
add the president's children to it
yeah just wants attention one do you
know anyone else yeah who impulsively
tweets to get attention but never like
their left is there anyone else like
that Tom I'm screening Tom's quizzes
he's got me you know but here look you
know Debra Messing Jim Carrey says some
crazy stuff
I'm just amused that you guys pay so
much attention because I am on their
side of the aisle and I think these
people have no relevance to a political
conversation to me it's like when the
right gets focused on John Boyd or Kid
Rock right or who else do you guys love
to pay attention to anyone Kanye West
Clint Eastwood con you and I'm thinking
you know I really I don't take political
advice or counsel from these folks but I
think it then it becomes like anybody in
Hollywood as a platform who affirms my
position oh I'm gonna like them but
anyone who contradicts me I'm gonna say
the one when clay wood was up there at
the RNC doing his thing you you were all
over that you were all over this week
you didn't act like that was no big deal
when fighting him up there that was the
ridiculous part even to this fact I
think he was invited I think yeah by who
the Republicans by Romney lot of people
say that was a mistake they shouldn't
have done it but it openly do it one guy
in Hollywood who's actually conservative
it's a population of leftist in
Hollywood it's a very tiny person
my point is none of them I don't see why
we pay attention to any unless it's to
mahkum okay what is the thing that what
was what is the Jared thing is that
something I don't know about the who's
calling them national security I know
because there was a whole dirty yes I
don't want to turn the segment into a
wonky situation yeah security clearance
drama with how they got their security
clearances and whether they got them
because the president players found the
system and he's bringing peace to the
Middle East we have a peace plan now